jacob degrom back on the hill in game
number one jake six and two and then
zero point five four era thus on the
season ronaldo cuny junior leads off and
he takes care of him quickly at 101.
the grump lays down his marker three
pitches one strikeout two out and nobody
out here's ozzy albies
and he takes care of albies on three
pitches
and eight pitch first inning for degrom
34 in a row he's retired in the first
inning that's come to bat no score
for the 11th consecutive start jacob
degrom has retired the side in order in
the first inning two of them via
strikeout and left-hander kyle muller
the top pitching prospect for atlanta
will go for the braves it'll be his
first major league start and pete alonso
will be the hitter
vr creeping down the line and that kicks
away and here comes vr and he'll score
the first run of the game
vr was halfway down the line when the
pitch was thrown and when it got away
from kevin smith
the r was able to score easily on the
wild pitch and the mets fashion a run
without a hit in the first inning
3-1 on the way
ground ball out to dansby sliding stop
to his backhand side pops up throws over
gets the out and that into the bottom of
the first inning but the mets pick up a
run without a hit a walk a ground out a
flyout and a wild pitch move er all the
way around the bases and at the end of
one inning it's one nothing new york
abraham almante leads off in the second
legram
with a left leg kick delivers swung out
and missed strike three he buried that
slider to the back foot again
look at him
that is
priceless right there
he knows that he's watching something
special and i think all that fans are
understanding that right now
cameron pilar such an inspirational
story for the new york mets you know
what happened to him here in atlanta
after undergoing all those surgeries the
nasal fractures and the like
one two pitch on the way swung on and
missed gets a strike out of pilar got
him with a fastball away
and one down near the bottom of the
second inning
yeah jacob degrom's hitting 423 this
season
the grom is 11 for 26 this year with six
rbis
he has
folks
six rbis that's more
that's two more than earned runs he's
allowed
or driven in more than he is allowed
that is just
that's like playstation numbers yeah
here's the 1-1 pitch
lifting in the air to left-field dan's
be drifting back haradia coming in this
will be the center fielder herrera who
makes the catch and the met strand
runners at second and third
so no runs one hit no errors and two men
left we have played two we head to the
top of the third inning with the mets
leading the braves one to nothing
yamaha radio leading off in the third
inning
one two coming to radio
what can't he do
cuny struck out his first time he
launched his 100th career homer
yesterday
again the 1-2
struck him out high heat from the ground
five strikeouts the second time he's
gotten acuna
one nothing meant
the grom goes to the high fastball above
the zone acuna misses two in the inning
it's degrom's fifth strikeout of the day
and now degrom has faced 23 straight
batters since he allowed his last hit no
runs no hits in this inning one walk
the r walked his first time
created a run out of it
here's the one two from mueller
boy that was yep got the call third
strike
looked like a delayed called strike by
may one out base is empty here's
francisco lindor who's over one with a
ground out the 2-2
is caught on a missed excellent breaking
ball back-to-back strikeouts three of
them for kyle
now nobody on three infielders on the
left on the right rather for albies who
bats left hand
well that was a clinic right there from
degrom slider changeup slider and albies
is a strikeout victim for the second
time
one out kevin pilar the batter
wind in the pitch hard hit ball left
side diving stop by reilly he gets to
his feet throws him out what a play by
austin reilly
great job
take his time getting up even though
it's a fast runner you got plenty of
time we've seen him kind of hurry some
throws lately over to first
that one you see how he kind of gets on
top of it more
well big moment now here
in a one-nothing game
the grom getting a little unsettled here
with two out a walk in a long double and
now sandoval to pinch it with the tying
and go ahead runs in scoring position
and sandoval pops up on the first pitch
the ark comes in to call
side retire
big pitch by degrom
they're now two for 23 against him this
year with runners in scoring position
so jake will leave after five innings he
lowers his
world leading era to
0.50 and he's now thrown 30 consecutive
scoreless innings
it will also mean that jake will be the
first pitcher in history
to allow one earned run or less in 12
straight starts not just 12th straight
to start the season but any 12 start
span in major league history
so here are jacob degrom's numbers
through 12 starts
72 innings
27 hits
nine walks
117 strikeouts
it's like you took a video game and
turned all the dials
to make it
the most indomitable player you could
ever create
and that's what jacob the grandma's big
his era is 0.50
albert almore jr will lead it off
hung up and riley another great play at
third
that's two of them for austin and now
maura just waves his hand dismissively
can't believe it while the braves dugout
loves it almost the exact same play
yeah another great play mets fans are
thinking
we got another third baseman over there
we got to
deal with this who is this guy
a couple great plays by austin
so now jeff mcneal will make his return
to action
last time we saw jeff was in saint
petersburg on may the 16th
when the second time he heard his
hamstring remember he cramped up earlier
a week before he gets a nice ovation for
his return to us
he lights one into center field and
radio will have to play it on the hop
mcneil first pitch he sees off the
injured list hits a rope for basic
newcomb brought in to face dom smith
who's just one for six against him
and rifles one down the right field line
that'll go in the corner for extra bases
neato is in mcneil scores here's vr
coming to the plate he will score
a bases clearing double for dominic
smith and it's four nothing new york
aubie's
in his last 18 games coming into today
11 extra base hits and 16 runs batted in
as this ball is tomahawk to deep right
field ozzy albee's has left the building
a two-run homer and the braves are on
the board it's now four to two
another extra base hit for ozzie his
11th homer
kevin smith bounced to third
double
first pitch on the way popped in the air
behind first base smith back now into
foul ground makes the one-hand catch put
it in the books